good evening everyone well that's you
can go ahead so it looks like we've made
it to the final panel invited talk
element of Naropa 2018 I'm seeing a lot
of tired people out there after an
entire week of intense conferencing this
is a problem for me as a moderator of
the final panel because I'm actually
hoping to get as much participation in
questions as possible coming up to the
front so I guess - in the spirit of
starting that out if I could get
everyone to actually stand up and
stretch out a little bit then you'll get
a little bit more energy for this final
sprint to the finish that we have we
we're going down the finishing chute all
right just lean to the right to the left
all right
Circle your arms shake out your legs all
right all right I'm are seeing a lot
more energy out there than it was before
all right now now all this is happening
if I could ask all the the panels in the
final panel that come take the stage and
I'll start introducing you while you
well you're on the way up you can sit in
any order you like
all right so as the panel is sitting
down I'm going to introduce them so we
can get moving as fast as possible the
panel has five members the first member
is just making sure everyone's here the
first member is Zubin government
he is the chief scientist of uber and is
by no means a stranger to the NURBS
community he is significantly advanced
the field in probabilistic modeling with
many fundamental contributions and in
the area next we have Julian Cordoba say
who is research director with element AI
at at its London office specializing in
that office and particularly
specializing in AI for good we also do
in our thanks for actually bringing
together the organizers of the workshop
he was actually the join of a number of
people that were bringing together bids
to organize the workshops on similar
themes and realizing that it actually
didn't make sense to have three separate
bids he brought together and that's how
what you're able to have such dense
panels and talks of so many leaders in
the field next we have Lisa Dao who is a
program manager with Ahmadiyya which is
a start-up developing ml solutions for
the healthcare industry then we have
David Danks who is a professor of
philosophy in psychology and head of the
Department of Philosophy at Carnegie
Mellon University he applies
interdisciplinary approaches to address
the human and social impacts when
autonomous capabilities are introduced
into technological systems finally rahul
Panicker is CIO for the what what hewan
e.i Institute for artificial
intelligence an independent nonprofit
Research Institute based in Mumbai India
developing AI solutions for social good
as the final panel the workshop we are
going to cover the organizational
practice
of good AI the panel will discuss
definitional incentive and outcome
issues within academia and industry and
at silver points throughout the hour
we're going to open the floor to your
questions I encourage the the panel to
respond to each other's thoughts this is
a discussion it's not a presentation as
much crosstalk as possible is encouraged
to start things out please join me in
welcoming the panelists okay
so jumping right in let me begin with a
question for the entire panel it could
each of you in turn give a brief
introduction to your organization's and
give an example of a program your orgs
do that is for the social good so
starting with Rahul to my left I suppose
so Shawn as you mentioned the what
Ronnie Institute for AI is a non-profit
AI research lab doing AI for social good
we are headquartered in Mumbai and
everything we do is free for social good
news and open access an example example
of a specific project we have lots of
air for social good projects going on a
specific one I'd pick is something we
are doing in neonatal health too many
low birth weight babies are getting
missed in the developing world once they
leave hospitals and so we are doing a 3d
reconstruction of image based
anthropometry from 3d reconstruction of
multiple 2d images so that a healthcare
worker with a cell phone can determine
if a baby is low birth weight or not and
she can measure its weight and baby's
weight and head circumference and other
vital parameters providing a parameter
for neonatal health in in rural areas
so images AI based their scare company
we're doing a solution for personalized
medicine to be a bit more specific we
are building our image where we are
acting at every much pretty much every
step of the biomarker discovery pipeline
so it means that we're building quoting
tool to build the correct data set were
building the tooling to curate and
structure rate the data as well as the
tooling to discover patterns and
correlate them to the clinical outcome
at image a my role as you said is a
program manager for the open innovation
team and external collaboration so the
title is very well chosen because we are
working with a clinical researcher and
AI a researcher in order to solve the
clinical question regarding your
question for the what is the project
that is an a good example for AI for
good and it's not for me to pick one
because on pretty much every project
that were having a team Asia right now
what I know is that if we solve it the
impact on the patient is going to be
very huge and we are talking about
saving a more time forever even saving
some people for some projects so it's
pretty hard for me to cherry pick one
like this so that's that hi everyone
thanks for being there on the last hour
of the last day of a crazy conference at
element AI we are a software young
startup we're two years old we're a
software product company co-founded by
yoshua and jean francois Kenya the idea
is that we try to put AI in all the
verticals and try to do that in-house
turning the classical startup model on
its head it's a little crazy it's a
little chaotic it's very much awesome
and the idea that we think that
companies now have a responsibility that
goes beyond our shareholders and beyond
a nice corporate social responsibility
report at the end of
year we think talent and especially
talent in a field of AI now he's looking
for purpose as we can see in the in the
latest news and the different open
letters from employees to their
companies and so a search from the
get-go we've decided to have an AI for
good component which concretely put the
talent directly in working with NGOs so
you know I'm a techie I'm gonna for you
I'm a techie I'm a scientist I have no
clue how to fix the worst problems but
you know we have tools maybe we can put
them to the service of the domain
experts that's what we're trying to do
concrete examples of that well we have a
whole team of 11 people working purely
on AI for good and that means
partnership with Amnesty International
that means concrete projects with them
so two of which you can see at the end
of the whole one being on finding
Twitter abuse against women on Twitter
and especially against women journalists
and women politician and working hand in
hand with human right experts and human
rights researchers I'm actually really
glad that some of the amnesty experts we
working with are in the room today and
came to see a more closely what is
nerves exactly so this is exactly the
type of partnership we want to build for
the long term going beyond the
low-hanging fruit and putting or
actually talent and time where our mouth
is great so so I just want to start with
what is AI is this AI for social good so
what is AI and what is social good I'll
be very brief so one way of thinking
about AI is systems that sense and act
and in some ways actually what uber does
in a city is sense what's happening in
the city and act in the city to optimize
certain things and it doesn't act alone
it acts in partnership with people with
if you look at the drivers they're three
and a half million drivers around the
world in 600 cities around more than 60
countries
and you know I sort of think of that as
sort of an AI for cities that's
hopefully providing a value because
corporations can't really survive unless
they provide some sort of values that
comes to like what is social good you
know it could be controversial people
would say oh well you know we're just
trying to provide value to our
shareholders although being a loss
making corporation so far we're
transferring a lot of wealth to drivers
and riders from venture capitalists at
this point but the value that we're
trying to provide is making the world
more efficient so moving people and
things around in the world and that is
really broadly the world including South
America India Africa a lot of the
developing world where this is
desperately needed in certain places and
you know it's clearly disruptive and you
know we could obviously talk about that
but as such a large agent around the
world although it's you know our mission
is pretty clear and what we do we also
have the opportunity to do a lot of
tremendously impactful positive things
in the places that we are and if you
remember there was a tremendously
you know damaging earthquake in Mexico
City and uber by being there on the
ground with the drivers and the crew
that we have in every one of our cities
was able to mobilize our drivers to
basically help people in in disaster
relief situations and we have to act
very very quickly to do that and we have
good experience with that if you think
about our role in Saudi Arabia by
empowering women to both ride and drive
I think we've had a positive effect
there on that half of society and you
know just as another example we're
pushing you know it's although Hoover's
started out sort of really catering for
an individual taking a car like a taxi
and so on there are literally billions
of people that really can't benefit
from that this is not really useful for
them and in part of in in many parts of
the world to reach the next billion
people we're really thinking about
higher capacity vehicles
you know mini buses and so on to serve
people in communities where it's it's on
demand as magical and wonderful that as
it is in in the developing in the
developed world but also incredibly
affordable cheap and so on and then that
lever that we have again you know it
could it could be good or bad but it
does create a lever to make the world
more efficient to reduce the impact of
transportation by making more efficient
move towards electric vehicles
eventually and hopefully add value to
society in that way Thanks so I'm going
to go out on a limb and guess that
nobody in this room needs me to tell you
what Carnegie Mellon is it's a pretty
familiar face around this conference but
what you might be less aware of unless
you've been in this room today is for
the whole day is that they're now at
this point over 50 faculty
five-zero at carnegie mellon who are
working on problems in the area of
essentially the impacts of AI either
developing technology with an eye
towards doing social good or working to
understand that technology or even more
interestingly trying to sit in between
those two both developing and analyzing
the impacts of the very things being
developed so it's not just a place where
there is some of the best machine
learning in robotics but it's also a
place that is taking really seriously
the challenge to think about what are
the impacts of the technology that we
are that we are building in Pittsburgh
and as well as education has come up a
few times as well as trying to ensure
that we are teaching the next generation
to think about these impacts whether at
the undergraduate level where we now
require all of our majors to take
courses and ethics and impacts of
technology to graduate fellowships that
are
voted to ensuring that our graduate
students have the opportunity and
freedom to think carefully about the
technology that they're building which
makes it difficult to pick out just one
project there have been multiple just
talked about here today so I guess I'd
rather say that I think one of the
things that's most important is actually
the sort of meta level which is our
ability to create interdisciplinary
partnerships a few people today have
talked about the need to have computer
scientists in the same room with
philosophers like myself or
psychologists or designers or historians
and it has not been easy but I think
that we've made enormous progress
towards making that a reality at
Carnegie Mellon that it's now I think in
large parts of the campus considered bad
form to develop technology without at
least having a cup of coffee with
somebody who can talk to you about the
impacts ethical social or otherwise of
what you're doing it's just part of the
culture now or it is at least becoming a
lot more part of the culture than it was
thanks everyone
so I'll move on to the next question
I'll address this directly at Julian why
why do your orgs engage in this activity
and the bigger question why are we
suddenly interested in AI for good
there's no mathematics for good
archaeology for good why now why a I
what happened well there's two aspects
to it the personal one is being a former
French academic obviously am politically
slightly on the left of Che Guevara so
the idea more seriously is to
essentially say hey we've got all these
fantastic tools that we are developing
as a community a machine learning
community these tools can have a really
transformative impact precisely as a zoo
being just reminded us therefore we have
a duty to think about how how we use
them
now that's both y yai in particular as
to why we're doing it you know
in with an element of why doing it
within a for-profit company because the
element is a for-profit company it's
simply that in the ecosystem in which we
operate right now a lot of resources are
in company companies are what is making
a lot of the world tick and if we want
to do things at scale and precisely make
sure that what we do does really scale
up these so far is a vehicle that we
need to find how to our Nass if we can
find by what we do show that the bar is
raised into what is expected from an
organization and from a company and if I
you know with this team show that more
companies should do it and we get tons
of people competing to do that then
mission accomplished
does anyone else wanna address that
question before I move on or so I come I
largely operate in the developing world
and there it is because we can and we
need to and there's a there's an immense
shortage of skilled manpower so if you
take a domain like healthcare or act we
don't have enough agricultural experts
and a couple of weeks ago I speaking
with
an agricultural scientist who gets 5000
whatsapp images a week from farmers who
click pictures of their crops and sent
to him saying should I be worried is
this a pest attack and you know that's
an image classification problem do you
think the opportunity within India for
AI for good is greater than that in the
more industrialized infirm and sized
world world or do you think that the
challenges involved if you look at the
opportunity for AI for good as the
amount of difference you can make I
would argue yes and this is true of many
parts of the developing world and that's
because now increasingly so AI itself as
well posed to make a difference there's
increasing penetration of smartphones
and there are large technology enabled
social programs that have been that have
rolled out over the last decade or so
that have provided the data pipelines to
all the infrastructure and human
resources needed and AI has the
opportunity to plug into and plug in
that and amplify thank you
any way else or okay let's move on I'm
gonna move through a series of theme
areas we're going to start with
basically talking about the state of
play and AI for good in academia as well
as industry and then moves through
safety and fairness regulation and other
mechanisms and then if we have any
additional time we might talk about
measurement of like how we can decide
what is what is good and how much of an
impact we're actually having in the
course of this movement so let me say to
the panel let's start with David on this
one
what do corporations see is their
responsibility and producing AI for good
and how is this different from academia
so I think that we actually face a
pretty significant structural problem
right now as Julian was just saying the
resources in many cases are in corporate
environments those of you have been
coming to nips for 20 years we've
noticed this it's a little bit the name
tags are a little bit different it
wasn't 8,000 people back in 2000 at the
same time the constraints are often much
greater in the corporate environment in
terms of you have as John havens put it
did we make our numbers you have a
certain number of responsibilities that
in academia quite frankly we often don't
have we have the freedom and luxury to
tackle problems that are not justified
on any standard cost-benefit analysis
but so the structural problems that
we've got a gap the people with the
resources are not necessarily free to
use them for social good the people with
the freedom don't necessarily have the
resources so what we need to be doing I
think is first of all admitting that
this gap exists and not dancing around
it not pretending that it doesn't exist
and then trying to solve it and here I
would suggest we could potentially look
for some guidance to another area
we're this exact same structural gap has
existed for 50-plus years which is
actually the development of drugs and
pharmaceuticals treatments for various
diseases there are a lot of diseases
that it is not profitable to create a
treatment for it but are nonetheless
interesting scientific problems and
biochemical problems and so finding ways
to have industry academic partnerships
and often facilitated by governments and
NGOs is I think something that we need
to be more aggressive about there are
some notable successes along those
fronts of having industry academic
partnerships but I think that we need to
be a lot more mindful and deliberate
about constructing them and having
frameworks for that if we really want to
see AI for social good take off in the
way that I think it I assume most of us
in this room want it to yeah I mean as
somebody who spent sort of 25 years in
academia in only the last two years in
industry it's very interesting to see
sort of different constraints certainly
in academia I felt that I was very free
to work on anything I wanted and the
cost-benefit analysis didn't have to be
very rigorous right in industry you know
companies are organized around missions
and you have to you have to understand
the mission of the company and sort of
work within those constraints but you
know I believe you know of course there
are there's a whole range and you know
many people would work would not work
for certain companies because of the
mission but I believe that there are a
lot of companies out there that can have
a tremendous impact through their
mission and the the big difference is
the impact so in a in a sort of setting
where it's not just the resources like
the data and the compute but also the
reach of the company and so that that's
that's a contrast as an academic it can
be frustrating because you may want to
do so
thing but you know it's it's hard to
actually implement it and and reach out
to the public with it alien from a
academia although not as many years as
zoo being I think that I'm really good
mindful that as David pointed we
collectively are the product of an
ecosystem even all the gigantic
companies that many of us are part of
now are here because all these
algorithms we developed them from
academia and we developed them through
open exchange of ideas of course I'm a
little worried when a company goes and
butchers a whole lab and you wonder okay
it's great for now but what in five
years when there's no more students so I
strongly believe in playing as part of
an ecosystem as working with academia
taking them as consultants or as fellows
but not as full-time employees if we can
avoid and as part of that you need to
explain precisely to make it work in a
sustainable way within a capitalist
system of incentives you know just like
in reinforcement learning you have an
environment you need to play by the
reward you need to be able to justify in
terms of cost-benefit why would a
company be part of an ecosystem why
would a company do some AI for good and
there's a few argument there one is
about talent again that is a really
strong message to every machine learner
here there are a few talents as hahoo
was mentioning there are a few of us we
have a tremendous moment now in our
industries to tell to our employers hey
you know what I'm coming to work with
you but I strongly believe that this is
where we should be going and where we
should be doing we thinned out through
the wall chaos within that through the
open letters within that through Google
dropping some contracts with Pentagon
because of its internal employees
feedback now that's the first angle the
second angle is if I want to be you know
the most cost benefit and most scenic
or say you have a client or customer who
wants to have AI in its company he
doesn't know necessarily what AI is but
once so even better you should know what
it is now
if there are different providers of
tools of expertise of talent
some of them being very all of them
being technically fantastic you can't
compromise on that but a few of them
being in addition very ethical having
ethical processes
I think ethical experts in the room well
even the most cynical customer will want
to go for that provider because it's it
decreases their exposure to risk of a
massive scandal like I'm rich analytic a
few years down the road so this is where
we can show that there is an interest in
putting the other six and nice ecosystem
at the core of your operation because it
just makes business sense I hate to I
feel very cynical when I explain that
but I believe it's important to
formulate it in this term so that we can
get to something that is sustainable to
add a bit on on that side too and when I
can tell from my point of view at image
I that I noticed that every time we have
formulate the the project or the
question about what is the benefit to
the patient like sort of naturally that
comes with it is that everyone
beneficiate of it including the economy
around it so that means that we're
winning at every level at the patient
level at the hospital level at the full
ecosystem at even the AI pure expertise
AI perspective because we are fostering
new research we are trying to resolve
new open question so I think that
switching the mindset to AI for good
really helps doing business like without
being cynical I I can really relate to
that
I will take a slightly different take on
this and say that AI for social good
should not just be a side activity for
large industry players but we need to
create allow markets such that they can
be industry created around di for social
good so if we look at healthcare there's
public health markets if you look at
infrastructure there's actually
companies that operate in that regime
and similarly we need to create
mechanisms in which companies can come
up that primarily operate in this domain
and that requires a number of things
like we need to create suitable data
markets we need to have regulations
about a robust evaluation mechanisms and
so on but many of these things have been
done there are some AI specific nuances
but otherwise many of these things have
been dumped and done in other domains
and that needs to be created in this
space thanks everyone for that I'm going
to open it up to questions for the floor
after one more questions so if people
want to get to the microphone there's
one right there
while they're walking over the
microphone I'll ask Lisa and/or Zubin on
this one civil society organizations
governments social institutions in
general seem to be rather confused by AI
as a phenomenon how to best interface
with it on at Lisa you you're in a
company that is treated very much as an
old industry and medicine is treated as
such in the rollout of products zhuben
urina like new at this point in a newer
industry or a new take on an old
industry that those institutions are
figuring everything still figuring out
how to handle it what are you seeing in
the like current approach of social
organizations to your areas of
application of AI and how are things
currently changing and influencing or
your developments and your your science
and your engineering
you know you're talking about regulatory
and stuff like this sure okay so it's
it's a so it's funny because it's a
really recurring question but should we
change like the way the law is organized
or even what you can do what you cannot
do with data and what's very interesting
is that we do believe that there's all
this heavy regulation area for a reason
that is to protect people and if you
want to do AI for good you need to not
go against this so it's really the
position that we're taking and that we
are having to build all of our system
and solution and tooling even to respect
that regulation so we do not take this
position when we're we are asking to
have a more flexible regulation or
things like this Excel there are a
couple points so in the sort of
ecosystem that we came into so we as a
company around eight years ago now so I
wasn't there but basically it was very
disruptive to the taxi industry right
that's the the main disruption that
happened and clearly that was a
disruption that was felt in every city
and it was a it was a case where
technology just made a service very
efficient where it hadn't been if it
that efficient before basically so there
are many examples of this where AI goes
into sectors that are not very
technologically driven and changes
things and I'm defining AI pretty
broadly it includes the sort of
algorithms that make all the decisions
that make the system efficient basically
and I think there'll be many more
examples of this over time we should
embrace it to the extent that is
providing a service that people want and
that it
is actually making society more
efficient I mean efficiency isn't the
only thing we should care about
obviously you know one concern this is a
side point really but one concern is
okay things are more efficient but how
is that benefit being distributed and
that's something we haven't really
talked about that aspect that I think
it's on my mind certainly but let me
talk about the regulation side because
that's another area where you know if
you think about it actually in everyone
I'm just talking about the main rides
business actually ubirr has a whole
number of businesses food delivery
freight trucks bikes scooters etc now
but the main rides business it operates
in in six hundred cities around the
world and actually every city has
different rules so you know dealing with
the regulations is something that we now
as a company certainly have fully
embraced and just having a conversation
with the regulatory environment in each
one of those cities and trying to
understand well which aspects of those
regulations are things that are there to
protect the public and there are many of
those right safety regulations for
example safety is a huge huge priority
for us you know for our business if
we're not safe that's that's gonna hurt
us but that's also formed public good to
provide a safe reliable service labor
laws so labor regulations are something
that we're obviously mindful of and
they're very different in in different
countries and you know we do we do have
a view that you can provide
opportunities in ways for the driver
partners that are different from
standard employment but you know that
that interacts with local regulations in
many places and so we have to work with
the local regulators so sorry you've
seen that AI when it's roll down in the
world is very very global and then it
kind of goes through a process of
localization and
refinement I mean that's what I see in
in our case but I think in in a lot of
cases as well you one size doesn't fit
all
and that's really like what we have as a
company and I'm sure it's true for a lot
of the other global companies is we
actually have a lot of local people on
the ground in each of those cities and
they understand like we had you know
wonderful videos of Jakarta right just
in the previous presentation and you
know they understand that the sorts of
services that you need in different
places around the world are different
that's why you know we we want to have
an extremely like cheap and reliable
service in some parts of the world
because that's what the people there
need do this are you reaching for the
microphone then we'll yeah I was just
gonna quickly note I mean another thing
that I think is important is helping the
companies appear are all engaged in AI
for good for the right reasons we all
know there are plenty of companies that
are not they are there to try and make
money and if it leads to social good
fine but they're not trying to so I also
think that there's a role an educational
role for local for these local
communities to understand and be able to
ensure that as technology enters their
communities it's entering it for the
good of the community and of the company
trying to find these win-win
partnerships I think it's it's important
to also recognize that sometimes the
best way to help is to help people know
what they should be asking for in the
first place all right well we'll go to
the patient people the microphone and go
ahead thank you on the note of knowing
what we should even ask for in the first
place so I'll make an observation first
and then I'll ask two questions the
observation is that as we get lots of AI
based services that make us more
efficient we do also lose anonymity in
many cases we could even take uber as
one
you know you just place the taxi
industry you have a more efficient ride
service but you now have to identify
yourself and so you get there faster but
you get there without being anonymous
you no longer have that choice right and
so that leads to the first question is
that actually social good you you know
you save time but you no longer have
this choice of anonymity versus not is
that actually a social good is it
positive is a negative is it just
neutral to lose this choice my second
question and this so that first question
for you then second question is more
generally if we took that it would be of
course better for people if they had the
choice but you know for businesses it
makes more sense to get more data
it makes mixed business sense to have
more data but if that is neutral to
negative on the social impact scale how
would we fix that would that be through
companies just deciding to operate
differently is that the regulation yeah
so two questions number one yeah I mean
it it's obvious that almost all modern
AI depends on data and you know that
creates this situation this trade-off
where the data is being used hopefully
to provide a service but you know
privacy concerns you know people may be
losing their privacy anonymity etc so oh
sorry you wanted to clarify that well
yeah I could clarify that I also believe
you could provide a similar service
without collecting someone's name like
you could just give them a unique
identifier and they read that code to
the driver like you don't have to have
that name exchange I think and you can
pay with Bitcoin like you could do this
just not me doesn't a sense but yeah no
I mean some of these things do make
business sense so let me just drill down
into this in particular so so one of the
things that is very important for us is
the safety of our riders and drivers
there's the you know in a system that
operates with 15 million rides a day
around the world this is a concern that
we have to
one aspect of have having the data is
that we can verify for example on the
driver's side for example we can verify
that the driver is you know has past
safety checks and police records etc on
the rider side of course there there
aspects of that product where people may
want other people to know that they've
arrived safely home right and so there's
a trade-off there as well that we can
provide through the technology but I do
believe that you know one could go too
far with that and I actually think that
regulations like the GDP are the general
data protection regulation which you
know all the major companies are
hopefully all complying with and is
certainly a major activity for us as
well strike a balance where at least you
have to be clear with your customers
what you're using the data for what
value you provide to the customer for
that data use and only use the data for
those things and not some other side
things that you know we're not mentioned
I mean I'm not a lawyer but this is my
hand-wavy explanation of how that
affects us and I welcome that I think
you know we're not in a we're not in a
pure capitalism right I don't think that
exists anywhere in the world
it always often operates under
regulations and the regulations need to
protect people including on the safety
and anonymity side on the more general
question I mean I think one of the
challenges is that we know that people
will get save a value privacy and then
they give up their data right and left
and I think this points to an issue that
I have not heard us talk very much about
in the AI for social good community
which is the risk that there's a kind of
inherent paternalism in a lot of what
we're doing what happens when the social
good conflicts with what I happen to
want
and how much of a I for social good does
have a kind of inherent paternalism in
it where we're saying no no this is
what's good for the community and I
think there's a risk there that is
particularly pervasive when we're
talking about data and privacy I don't
have an answer for it I just wanted to
to flag it as as a very broad challenge
I like the yeah the paternalism because
you could say well this is what we use
the data for and you can like
communicate that you could also give a
choice and a lot of the time I think
people give up so so easily because
there's no choice like if you want to
take an uber again you kind of have to
do it so we should also be careful to
not to assume that all users are capable
of exercising informed choice I think
that there especially the paternalism
and the question of regulations first we
need regulations around AI and we need
regulation Wistia and I think gdpr has
brought a little of that we need more of
that
we need more society involved in there
in terms of avoiding the paternalism I
think it's extremely important to
realize that we're not text saviors
we're not here to jump in and with our
magic tech fix the whole world on the
contrary we have tools that we are
bringing to society and we are a part of
society and we need to have in the
conversation but even more than in the
conversation as guides the persons who
are experts in the dynamics of society
will spend their entire careers studying
that now you find them some of them
indeed in university you find them in
NGOs you find them in government's you
want to work with them and provide our
tools to them and if that takes having
to explain what we do in depth and if
that takes having accountability that I
think this is something we should
embrace Tim neat in a panel earlier
today I was saying that in the fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
debate as a community we tend to focus
on the fairness because we can reduce
that to some metrics while the
accountability is extremely important
there and this is where regulations kick
in and this is where we need more
regulations with steel
thanks I'm seeing a rather large line
two questions I think I'm gonna kick it
back out there again give them a chance
go ahead the comment when Juliana's can
you speak up a little please the
microphone please
it's very close haitai I work in the
global development sector but I am a
machine learning scientist by training
in my sector you know we a lot of my
colleagues still sees machine learning
is this you know very mythical unicorn
that seem to be apt to stop but they
don't really know why it is and your
comment early on you know say it's a lot
about you know there are actually
different stakeholders our society and
they all need to be involved and you
want the machine learning community to
be able to provide tools to solve you
know help to help other parts of the
society so just a chance you know for
for the panelists you know what kind of
messages would you like to send to maybe
your counterparts maybe in the NGOs
maybe in the department sectors or maybe
other parts you know what help can they
provide the machine learning community
for us to develop better tools and
things like that thank you very much in
one very short answer
it's please let's take the time don't
believe the hype around AI has just sit
together and dig deeply into what we do
into what we have it's not a casual
competition take the data and run it's a
long duration partnership when we
understand what you do and you
understand what we do and from there
start with so low-hanging fruits and
keep going until we reach to the bigger
impact it's really about that working
together talking about working together
and all the good good questions and
debates that we have they were beginning
of conversation among the
stakeholders in Montreal and the result
was the declaration of Montreal ethical
principles that may inspire us in the
development of AI so I think it's very
important that everybody know about this
please read it it's in English as well
and following this declaration of
Montreal the conclusion or because we're
we're defining AI for good in industry
say as people in this industry would
like to support this ethic ethical
principles or we prepare to disrupt our
final financial model are we prepared to
say as an industry or company we will do
business otherwise not only thinking
about the bottom numbers at the bottom
line but maybe decrease the income
income to have more impact I don't know
I'm asking you what are you prepared to
to come what kind of compromise are you
prepared to do yeah so I suppose there's
two questions there of what what are you
willing to do in the the current state
towards they I get in terms of
sacrificing your profit motive and then
if I could layer one on one on top like
how can we appropriately shape companies
towards making that decision more
proactively like how how can social
institutions be put into place like
there's been some debate about
regulation already that hasn't been too
direct but how do we do it now I guess
the for the first question that Miriam
posted while the people and companies
trying to figure out what they're
actually able to say without setting
policy um I'll just first note that I
think one important thing is to
recognize that ethical and effective are
not necessarily opposites I mean I think
there's a point the Julian's been making
on a couple of occasions that if you
actually do ethical AI one of the things
you're probably going to end up doing is
careful design thinking about what it is
that the client or the user really cares
about and in the long run perhaps not in
the very short run but in the long run
that can often be a good business
decision so I think there's some times
as a short-run myopic focus that leads
people to not realize that in fact by
doing at the very least smart design
which has a lot of overlap it's not
identical with but a lot of overlap with
ethical features of AI or ethically I
think there's there's an opportunity
there for a business case to be made
that often I think doesn't get made I
love the Viets point about the people
from company thinking what they can do
and I'm currently saying hi to my press
relation person who's just hiding behind
her hand right now but sincerely I think
there's two aspects in there there's one
how do you change the incentives for
different companies because again when
Firstman learning agents operate based
on the reward system I reiterate what I
said earlier about this change either
can come from regulation but can also
come from all of us machine learners who
constitute these companies and we're now
for a few years at least a critical
resource that is how to have a change
there the other point is about again how
can we phrase the different good that we
are doing how can we make it work within
the existing the existing system which
is the point I was making
actually Third Point which out of two
points is quite a bonus is keeping in
mind systematically the notion of of
tragedy of the Commons we can be
extremely efficient for every individual
customer yet be completely ruining the
one resources that we have in common
that's where initiatives like the AI
Commons that Amir was mentioning on on
Sunday can be extremely
interesting and need to be investigated
much further so I'll come in briefly I I
completely agree with David that you
know doing the right thing and being
effective and having a good business
model or not in opposition although you
know it is a there is tension sometimes
and so you know this is very clear and
you have to have companies with the
right leadership with strong leadership
that sort of permeates that throughout
the organization I think that's super
important on a sort of on a deeper note
in a previous previous presentation
today somebody pointed out one of the
speakers pointed out that all these
things are social constructs so you know
this whole core you know this is I'm now
speaking personally but the whole
concept of a corporation and you know
the profit motive and so on these are
these are things that society has
constructed right and and you know it is
very clear that we live in a world with
finite resources and that money doesn't
constitute happiness and fulfilled lives
and you know it would be amazing I don't
know whether we're we're stuck in a game
theoretic local minimum or something
like that but it would be amazing to to
figure out how we could create new
viable social social constructs that
would be viable in the sense of being
able to survive and thrive and be
efficient like capitalism allows systems
to do but also that that operate within
the constraints of our planet and the
needs of society and people I'd love to
see that I don't know how to do it but
it's small problem yeah okay let's go
back out to the microphone since we
still haven't gone through the backlog
there Johnny
like to stores quick so marvin minsky
wrote in an e-mail in 1993 someone had
asked him you know about his funding
processes during is the early point of
his career and he said that had the US
government not funded artificial
intelligence it wouldn't have it
wouldn't have taken off because
companies were too short-sighted to
believe that such a thing could exist
so that's Story number one story number
two is about an earthquake in DC that
that that caused some damage to the
Washington Monument that cost fifteen
million dollars to repair Congress
didn't have the money they had seven
eight they offered seven and a half
million dollars and the head of the
Carlyle Group which is a hedge fund
offered another 7.5 and was kind of
celebrated for it now the head of the
Carlyle Group
Recker identified and then exploited a
loophole in taxation in the u.s. that
cost the public one hundred eighty
billion dollars and what I'm worried
about here is I guess rhetoric when we
talk about change and when we paint
visions of the future
I feel like there's a bit of
disingenuous nests or even gas lighting
where we're told that what's happening
here is for us and it's better and it's
efficient
if efficiency was the goal especially
for this field I would think that we
would want to go straight to taxation
and make sure stop corporate loopholes
stop corporate you know minimum a
Facebook page something like four
thousand dollars in the UK last year so
if efficiency is the goal that's really
what you believe I think you need to
come closer to our side and help
articulate you know a different or a
different vision of efficiency another
example is like buses are really
efficient and an uber makes it perhaps I
don't want to target just uber I think
this is a bigger problem than just do it
but what I'm asking for is I guess your
help
when we talk about these things I I
implore you to to not adopt language
about change that isn't really real
change that the sort of substantial
change when you go home you know your
brother or sister has a better job than
they had the other day the day before
because I know you can characterize
stories of successes but there's equally
we could spend the rest of the day
talking about the people whose lives
have been horribly disrupted in ways
that didn't need to happen
yeah so that's that's not really
question but I guess one thing I'll put
it this right I would love your help
also to know what are the limits like
you guys are at big corporations what
can't you say what can't you do because
we need to help you also collective eyes
a larger probably don't like when people
keep saying yeah but that's capitalism
[ __ ] because this is something we all
have to fix or my generation and my kids
generation and their kids generation do
not have what you have had the benefit
of having and I just I'm pissed off
about that I guess yeah all right no I
I'll take this first and if somebody
else wants to comment that's great look
I you know I think it's it's pretty
clear that if we just let corporations
go rampant and we have you know
competition over tax regimes between
cities and states rather than
cooperation then you know this this
isn't gonna be a great state of affairs
right you know personally again I'm
speaking personally here I've been
living in the UK I enjoy paying my taxes
because you know we have national health
service and all sorts of other things
that I think are good uses of taxpayer
money and you know I I would welcome a
more equal regulatory tax regime where
you know the benefits that are being
produced by corporations can feed back
into the public purse and hopefully with
the responsible governments that then do
good things with that money and you know
I also want to say that yes this stuff
is really disruptive and you know it's
it's not disruption means that people's
lives change and sometimes they change
for the worse as a result of all of this
technology and that certainly happened
we
or in the industrial revolution and cost
upheavals and you know we may have
upheavals now with the rate of
disruption and you know we as people as
citizens need to come together and
figure out what to do before it gets bad
right corporate structures are not
really well designed to to deal with
that it needs to be a partnership
between companies governments NGOs and I
don't see any other way of doing it yeah
probably note that around the same time
that disruption became a a bad word
within the technical technological
communities yeah I forget became one of
the the watchwords there we still have
four people in the line here we are very
short of time at this point and we've
gotten through maybe a third of the plan
material at this point but I'm not going
to stop good conversation so if the
questioners the microphone can ask short
succinct question well we'll go as fast
as possible here go ahead have any plans
to make use of that large and unique
unique database of traffic in the world
to apply it to problems like you heard
about Jakarta I found your set of UI
problems you're tackling rather non
compelling
compared to many other things have seen
so I'm wondering what you're planning to
do with that database to apply it to
like traffic problems around the world a
very very quick answer we have a program
called uber movement that releases data
to partner cities and it's free for
those cities to use and it has helped
many cities to improve public services
and we are expanding that so yes we want
to work in partnership with the cities
go ahead so I've had many many arguments
with colleagues where I've essentially
been like you really need to care about
social good and they're like
my incentives aren't aligned I have a
paper to get out I have a product to
push out and I think on this panel there
have been a number of suggestions for
basically how companies and entity
should be thinking about these things
but I think from my seat there they're
not and so I guess the question is how
do we take clunk like what concrete
steps can we take now to ensure that
these incentives are aligned for
individuals and corporations to do real
social good as the previous questions
that not just lip service to social good
but to actually be doing real social
good on a day to day basis like what is
what do we as a community need to
concretely do right now to make that
happen thanks for the question and I
think that something very important is
about communication how can reach with
the public explain what we do and have
feedback understand the fear especially
in medical I hear a lot of what are you
guys doing with my data what will happen
like people are really scared and I
think it's our job and our
responsibility to explain what we're
doing with that where we're going and to
reinsure a bit and to hear but like to
hear the fear and and explain where it's
true and when where it's not true for
example something that comes a lot to my
here is a medical people telling me but
we're gonna replace doctors which is
absolutely not the case and I think we
need we really do need to reinforce a
message and say it again like where we
are trying to at least at image a we're
trying to propose solution that will
beneficiate to everyone and so the more
the more we communicate on that side and
the better I think it's going to be for
especially for social good another way
is exactly what you're doing right now
which is speak up and lead by example
talk to your colleagues if they don't do
it do it yourself and lead and show the
impact that this can have I think it's
really down to each of us at this stage
and in this room
- yeah get the stuff down and it will
follow one really small but I think very
effective change don't talk about
replacing humans talk about augmenting
humans now I I would ask so incentives
needs to be changed yes I would also
suggest that your colleague stop
pretending like they're helpless
reinforcement legion learning agents and
actually we are all creatures of agency
here and we have the ability to make
choice would would be okay to
collectively say there's a commitment on
the room to try and change the reward
function on these things towards
rewarding AI for social good works that
like those lining the walls I think we
go ahead role I say the the rewards
don't just have to be extrinsic they can
also be intrinsic okay and I think we
what functions apply to systems a
corporation is very much a sister but as
individuals I believe we have slightly
more choice as well was reminding us
okay next question and I think that
we're probably at the end here it seems
to me that some social goods are goods
from everyone's perspective like curing
diseases like malaria or AIDS but like
whether uber for example is doing social
good in Toronto from a rider as a as a
rider who is living in a city with a
pool public transportation you are doing
very good but as a taxi driver who paid
thousands of dollars for a taxi driving
license you're not doing a socially good
thing so I was thinking how corporations
are going to handle this different point
of views and perspectives when they talk
about social good
clearly social good is a complex topic
in the sense that actually you know what
do we for the for the nerds in the
audience that at least like what are we
trying to optimize you know are we
looking at at optimizing for the lowest
end of of the scale in terms of the
least privileged are we looking to
optimize on average what can we give up
in one case or rather I honestly I don't
have good answers for you I do feel that
and this is why I choose to work for
uber I do feel like on the whole there
is a net positive but we have to create
social structures so that the people who
are disrupted are not left with you know
a terrible situation and that's
partnership between corporations and
social structures like governments I
would say one thing I would also say and
I apologize I'm gonna get up on a tiny
bit little very small short soapbox and
just say we if I put on my machine
learning hat you if I put on my
philosophers hat um we don't have to do
this alone
so the problem of pluralism of values I
want one thing you want something else
are different levels of values questions
of fairness questions of agency autonomy
there are people who literally have
spent their lives their disciplines that
have spent hundreds of years asking
these questions and they haven't
necessarily put it in the language of
machine learning in computer science but
they have had unbelievably important
insights about the nature of these
phenomena and how to address them so I
encourage you if you find yourself
wondering yeah but is this good for
everybody or what do I do when these
people want it but these don't go talk
to a sociologist go talk to a political
scientist go talk to an ethicist they're
not gonna try and write code on your
behalf but they can help you understand
how to think through your problem in a
way that you're not having to reinvent
the wheel and start from scratch and
just kind of guess oh maybe
this is a good enough solution I realize
that's difficult when there's the push
to market because this is a I have to
stop and spend an hour calling somebody
up and talking to them but I strongly
encourage everybody to do that
there's unbelievable resources out there
who want to work with you and help you
do a better job with thinking through
the problems you face you don't have to
go it alone okay so unfortunately we are
out of time I'm sorry to let last person
at the microphone there but encourage
you to continue the discussion out after
the this point and before we move on to
the last short element of the workshop
which is presenting the awards for the
submissions I would like us all to give
a strong rally and a round of applause
for the panel thank you
you